skin condoms you know what it is skin
condoms this smooth you know why they
call skin condoms because it's supposed
to feel like skin on skin
she'll feel good the way the Lord it
feels as good as the Lord men fit to
feel almost skin condoms they come to
cool rapper
and a goofy blue stuff black and gold
and it's all good man hey this feels
good if you hear this is awesome they
taste great comfortable I saw some times
up the water just to sleep in even if
I'm not [ __ ] I just pull one on just
to make me sleepy
he's pulled Rambla for today's show to
receive free shipping on all skin
products you buy condoms not on that's
pulled rebel
Oh Scottie headband with no home search
under work search these sweatpants
get all types of this cause man you
gotta get some clothes if you got old
clothes get some new clothes comfortable
stuff you don't like what they got build
a fund you keep it and look good feel
good
Matt Wilden that's a cool name too it
could be restaurant mac world and
comprised with that name of things in
life welcome to Episode III Eve of the
handsome Rambla podcast
Hannibal Buress is Tony trim hey we're
here in Chicago man we're my in my
building main this is the first thing
I've done in this building man where
feels good what do you think of the
place man it's nice it's very you've
come a long way my friend Thank You Man
mm-hmm three apartments you're
officially a homeowner uh homeowner it's
three separate furnished apartments I
don't even think I want to run them out
I think I just wanna is that weird is
that I that would be fitting with my
whimsy to just have three just instead
of getting a house I just have three
different apartments I mean this would
be considered like a big-ass crib if you
took all three floors yeah that's dope
it feels good it feels different
yeah that's part of me I'm still getting
used to it
where you know it's kind of new so I'm
I'm one I'm thinking should I be here
champion and I remember oh yeah it's
mine
or even the other day before we before I
hit the road before I headed to the
airport I was sleeping here and I was uh
I was uh I was I was kind of trying I
was starting to rush cuz I was thinking
oh I gotta get out here I gotta check
out I gotta get out of here before you
know I'm just so used to being in a
hotel or somebody else's [ __ ] and I had
to and I got moving but it wasn't it
wasn't I was like I didn't have that I
didn't have to rush I could have laid
there so it's all good man Spencer had
an interesting week an interesting week
class of travel lots of stuff going on
wait did you take the 6:00 a.m. train
this morning absolutely not absolutely
not no I got it I got a real car I got
Irene Irene at the young for fusion and
hit the road only I listen to the just
about a total I've listened to a handful
of songs but for if it was a two and a
half hour drive yeah I listen to two
songs for two hours of it
why just cuz I really like those songs
so you listen to those two songs on loop
it's just back and forth but though
mostly it was wet yeah offered a new
tribe album is the track halt enough
that's the one that I ran back where we
will listen to them enough it's smooth I
listen to it over and over I probably
listen to it 30 times today
what yeah man I listen to music
passionately that's crazy man like I
have a hard time trying to listen to the
same song listen to it over and over man
you're crazy
that's like that song what's wrong with
that I do that all the time I just
didn't it was that and
Williams story about Saba you're crazy
man and I just listened to those over
and over and then I bring in another
track I played a Flying Lotus track what
is the the track it was a the Flying
Lotus track I was play it's a weird when
it came up on pad and I heard it before
it came up on Pandora let me see what
I've of my recently played Joyce was but
uh it was a Oh dance of the pseudonym oh
that's a great song yeah that's all so I
brought I brought that in once yeah and
then we're back to uh went back to that
that's off a cosmic grandma
yeah cosmic grandma dancer the pseudonym
s track is this this is uh it's a weird
it's all over the plate
[Music]
I love FlyLo he's like he's like Jay J
Dilla on acid yeah so yeah just listen
to two songs mostly for the entire Drive
and it felt good man I'm glad I took
that right with my friendís I don't do
that when somebody yeah ride it when I
listen to the same song you gotta be a
little more considerate we gotta be like
she's gotta be somewhat of a you know a
host an entertainer but sometimes I'll
just listen to the same song about 40
times man and just get in the zone
though yeah you know it's funny actually
when I was driving back because I had
because there are two friends old
friends from college and they happened
to come to the show so I was like
Hannibal wants to put me on a 6:00 a.m.
train so I'm just gonna head back with
y'all and I hopped in and then they were
listening to music for like the first
half hour there they're both rappers or
they're playing their cuts and I was
like check this out and I played a Joey
purp song I never really into it and
then I played another one in another
song and then all of a sudden I felt all
this pressure like yeah it was for the
next hour and a half man yeah yeah I
played totally different stuff get put
under pressure went out if I'm in a car
with a group of people versus if I'm
just I'm still playing stuff that I
would listen to but I'm trying I'm
getting a little I'm different of course
I'm not repeating songs but I'm trying
to appeal to everybody play some
different stuff show my range how do you
Jam isn't that you can't just it's
serious right yeah and you you feel a
lot of like man this this one when we
did the Bonnaroo and we were going back
in the shuttle and the whole SNL cast
was in there yeah and then I took over
the aux cord and then I was like why did
I do this did you get it yeah you wanna
you gotta nail it man you get everybody
yeah in good spirits as they go to the
next place um cuz you can spoil the
night by playing the wrong track you can
mess it up you didn't if not spoil it
you can kind of just you could
definitely put it in a weird spot if you
have that plan some good [ __ ]
getting there playing some [ __ ] I'm
gonna get I'll grab the Ox court and I
put on it goddamn podcast about flipping
houses to say don't even get the Ox
court and then just put on WTF with Marc
Maron fresh air the Ox court throne is
Terry Gross real quick give me the Ox
court so I could put on Freakonomics
podcast oh man
I had fun Elsa I'm glad I get to relax
this is the tour is pretty much done
mostly it still some markets to hit we
got a hit Austin Texas got a Houston
Dallas hidden Phoenix the day before
Thanksgiving November 23rd checking
around in Phoenix so got some other
smiling
la vegas milwaukee madison Minneapolis
Miami Atlanta it's a handful of cities
to still give ooh can we just do it Lana
we did do we did the Laughing Skull in
Atlanta oh yeah that's right it was a
small yeah that was the smell yeah we
did a small so yeah it still mode the
bulk of the tours done and we got a yeah
that was the night that wasn't like we
paused the show for the Cavs game we did
of the of the finals and I was on stage
and it was in the fourth quarter and so
I just stopped the show I wanted to see
I wanted to see our players we stopped
the show and we somehow was able to get
it on the TV and I just commentated the
last moments of the Cavs game because I
didn't want to be that's one thing yeah
I didn't want to miss it
yeah and so we kept it going and yeah
that was it that was a fun time that was
a fun time but yeah it was almost done
but before I headed out last week yeah
Wednesday was a Wednesday or Thursday it
was Wednesday night in Chicago sticks
who was a drummer and chance to rappers
bench and the drummer in the social
experiment he has a jam night at tonic
room great venue here in Chicago
he asked me to do a set at the gym night
and I agreed to do it it was they had a
great band it was packed and so I'm you
know he was it was a fun time I walk up
everybody's freestyling an outside
chance was out there
Malcolm London and I jump in I bust
freestyle real quick
and you know watch some people perform
with the band and then I go in and I'm
waiting for my turn to go onstage I'm
just assuming that they just wanted me
to do a stand-up set yeah when I get
onstage and then the it's like it's like
a five piece band peter cottan tells and
sticks this guy Malik this other guy
Malik and does drama guy I forget his
name Evan or something maybe so if it's
five musicians up to em Malcolm was
playing Keith and so I'm expecting
everybody to leave as soon as I get up
there and he's gonna leave and I just do
a set and then the whole band just
stayed up there okay I guess we're doing
this now and so I started doing set and
then I would wrap and just make up songs
on a spot and then I would going to
stand up a little stand up and then try
to use something for my stand-up and
then make a hook I came up with a couple
songs on a spot
I got hooks man let me hear what I got
hooks I don't write a new buzz if they
PT Cruisers all right new a PT Cruiser
alright new buzz if they PT Cruiser get
out of here you's a loser
that's my that I came up with that all
right in lieu in it yeah and the band
was rocking with me hooks I like that a
fresh cut you know you know it's
something about my haircut being fresh
it was a fun time rocking out with a
band man it was a it was a fun set I
want I want to give me a throat you know
if you want a verse if you want to hook
it up the handsome Rambo is the handsome
Rambler at gmail.com if you want to hook
for me drop that bag off I've dropped
that bag off and I got hooks hooks for
days got bars
I got bars I'll show you where to go
like
ways I got hooks for days scuffed my j's
just grabbed another j's [ __ ] the KKK
Hey
I smoked an L what's up with em in them
yo hey God do that you gotta bring in
that signature laugh with the raps
rhymes when it was a fun time man it was
a fun it was a fun show now I wish I did
a cover though when you have a band
there you got a you know just bust out
of cover that was the easiest thing I
was there sitting there
dude it was you know taking the tough
road trying to make up songs on the spot
what did you cover I said I wish I did I
wish I did i Kanye strong with flashing
lights or do a dial or crews conflict I
hey I just wish I did something else cuz
it was a great band and they were there
you know they finally could you know
play whatever and follow you wherever
you want to go GLC performed so GLC ever
heard about them in a minute GLC with
the is immediate did uh what does GLC
stand for good luck charlie for real
good good good good love cooking great
good looking cooking grates laughs champ
I don't know what VLC's dance for okay
so you know is this one of those things
you just take what it is GLC GLC he did
his uh data's verse of spaceship did his
very strong drive slope off of uh lay
registration it was cool chance perform
did a couple songs which assigns a
chance to Sharon's did same drugs okay
and he did something else and he did no
problem there's like 60 people there
it's pretty cool
okay it was a fun time then hit the road
Kansas City Kansas City was a good time
thanks to everybody came that was the
day after well two days after the
election
Trump won I was wrong in my prediction
Donald Trump
you were completely opposite opposite I
was off that if you listened to last
week's episode as
I thought Trump won the popular vote in
Hillary will win the electoral college
and it was flipped well Hillary won the
popular vote and Trump won the electoral
college but now the host of The
Apprentice is the president it's crazy
it's pretty crazy how was it I was in a
I wasn't in a great mood
on Wednesday the 10th when I woke up was
Wednesday the 10th or whatever it was a
night I wasn't in a great mood it kind
of wore up but no it did it just felt
weird I guess it was just because it was
so we were just joking about it so much
what if Trump was president doesn't that
yeah what if Trump was president and
then it happened and now we gotta kind
of deal with and some people people
people said he's not my president
he's not my here's your favorite
president
it's just you don't it's just like you
should kid if your uncle's drunk uncle
he's a weirdo you can't relate that my
uncle yeah your uncle that [ __ ]
just get drunk all the time he is the
president and you know is it's weird cuz
you know the stuff he said but I guess
he connected to people and uh and then
he just connected somehow
which is crazy because he's a he's a
billionaire that came from money and
somehow connected with people that yeah
I mean I guess some how do you feel
about like now there's like all these
you know there's like these companies
where they're CEO or ever like supported
Trump or supports Trump or whatever and
then people are like you should boycott
these come how do you feel about that
like say you owned a bunch of like New
Balances right right right uh-huh
and then what did I say came out saying
that they're white they're white people
sneakers in hours do you like that like
would you just throw away all your New
Balances not like huh well how would you
deal with that situation
this is really
I don't know man it's just I mean you'll
know it's a lot of thing well you don't
I mean if they openly say but there's
other things where people don't say it
but they did it so am I supposed to you
can't enjoy [ __ ] if you yeah exactly
exactly if you I mean if you really knew
everything about everybody yeah what
their political things were what their
ideas were did you probably wouldn't be
able to have [ __ ] you would be able to
enjoy any points to cut off that leg I
don't know what the commie if he was
straight up like I don't like black
people then I guess it's just yeah it's
wit cuz people you know I don't know man
he's supposed to boycott somebody just
because their political views and I'd
get the thing with the Trump thing is
not that I feel like a lot of stuff he
said was to get elected which is [ __ ]
up yeah cuz you he's dialing back on it
a bit but you know is that well it's
becoming more and more obvious than it
was just all showed you see but now his
his base a lot I mean some of his base
the alt-right movement and some his base
is very you know empower and this is a
different it's a different energy man
and is is really fascinating I mean do
you think people are being dramatic when
they're like I feel like I'm not safe
out here and this and I think people are
being dramatic or evening that's you
think that's like some Facebook social
media stuff getting out of hand or do
you think that is actually a direct
result of this um because I haven't felt
yeah terribly denied you can't discount
people's emotions really troodon him
saying yeah I says they don't feel safe
then now don't feel safe I mean yeah
it's just I mean it's unfortunate I
haven't looked much and said as this guy
that he he announced as his strategist
Brett was his name Stevie Bannon Steve
Bennett yeah Steve banning he looks like
Brian White from the blue-collar
comedies I mean I guess his whole thing
is that they say he's got ties with I
don't know if that's true or if the way
it was spun but he's got ties with the
KKK or something like yeah you know was
it's not a uh it's a his wit is it's not
good if when Trump makes moves and then
the leader of the KKK a good [ __ ] man
yeah that's not a good way that doesn't
feel good yeah that's a good one ya know
so I think that's what upsets people is
it to do from the KKK really [ __ ] with
Trump yeah yeah man yeah yeah it's just
routing them
oh good [ __ ] yeah yeah it's rough yeah
do that she's very intimidating uh I
don't know man Donald Trump from Russell
Vince McMahon and he's president now I
don't know man that's not what this
podcast is about this oh we don't you
know it's funny though when you see no
I'll see you know entertainers or
athletes they'll post something about
you know and that liking Trump and then
you know you'll see comments where
people their fans a stick to stick the
comedy stick to basketball politics
isn't your thing okay the [ __ ]
president isn't even a politician yeah
you can't say for somebody else to not
talk about politics willing to do that
has the highest office in politics has
absolutely no history in politics
that means anybody can talk about those
say oh I don't come here to your page
for political views people could talk
about what they want to talk about and
if you you know and it's up to you to if
you want to unfollow that person but
don't say don't try to I when people try
to diminish entertainers on their own
you know on their platform on their you
know Twitter or their Instagram you
follow an um people can say what they
want to say no
say that they can't say that because
they are comedian or they are singer
they are athlete that they don't have a
right to have an opinion when the
muhfucka Trump wrestled Vince McMahon in
a hair vs. hair match he's not a
politician but so we'll see it's
fascinating stuff man but yet Casey was
a good time things everybody that came
through the show in Kansas City and we
went to Cincinnati Cincinnati was live
man Cincinnati was live Cincinnati was
an unexpectedly good crowd like the
crowd the energy in Cincinnati Friday
night was amazing they gave me way more
energy and laughed and I deserved with
those jokes it was a good vibe it was it
was it was good it was a lot a lot of
tweets saying thank you so much for
making this terrible week awesome that's
what else has been happening to where
yeah people are just more appreciative I
guess it's a different company the last
right now I begin a different response
from people after shells versus you know
it would be normally good show thanks
for coming through that was fun and now
it's oh man I needed that this week I
needed that Masum I'm happy to give a
man I'm happy to give
[Music]
was that you under my helix mattress
watching an actress tried on the TVs
hands of the best it was cracked helix
mattress so I'm like the fabric it fits
with my whole body this mattress is the
[ __ ]
regrets what helix they fit it to your
body helix mattress go to helix Leacock
you answer a few questions and they'll
run a 3d bio mechanical model of your
body through some algorithm and you just
get a super listen man I want to get all
technical you don't talk even water your
technical information for me helix
matches they make it for your body it's
unique for your back you have a hundred
nights to try it out and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a hundred percent refund no
questions asked
they do have to ask questions where do
you live what tycoon pick up the
mattress but besides that no questions
asked on helix week.com slash Rambler
and get $50 off your order
helix sleep dot-com slash ramble helix
yeah
[Music]
I was flying from Cincinnati to New York
and I miss my flight
also I don't know if y'all know I'm the
Michael Jordan of missing flights I
think I mean I don't know I mean I don't
have a document but I've I've I've
missed more flights than some of you
have taken who do you think to brag
about but I just miss black some sense I
mean I never missed a gig because of it
but I've missed a lot of flights I
always make the shoto somehow you always
make the show I always make the shows a
couple days before but it's now because
a flight is never gonna travel but if
I'm on if I'm you know tell him about
tell him about what happened that when
we were in Boston were played at the
Wilbur Oh Wilbur the Wilbur in Boston
I forget what happened did I miss the
flight or an average you took that [ __ ]
you took like $1,000
uber you wouldn't know I'm trying to
remember why I think I've missed the
flight in it no I'm a flights were
delayed and then a bunch of them was
sold out from New York to Boston and so
then to make the gig I had to say I took
an uber from NYC to Boston a four-hour
uber to the tune of about a thousand
dollars but wait but wasn't there
something happening where like you
forgot your ID then you to go back and
then you went back to the airport or
something like well Nate tells there's
not important the main detail is that I
took a four-hour uber from New York to
Boston because it was in that moment the
only way the only option for me to make
the gig on time but I called American
Airlines to change this flight to later
from Cincinnati to New York on a
Saturday and this is the thing this is
the [ __ ]
this is what I've known this but it
could be so arbitrary sometimes where
the answer that you get so I call them
and I said I want to change this flight
and I couldn't take this morning if I
don't want to change to this two o'clock
flight or whatever and then they say
okay could out be a $200 change feet one
thing to change fees are pretty
arbitrate with some the person I mean if
they like the tone of your voice or some
[ __ ] or just like your phone vibe they
just might waive the change for its net
it's never done I don't think it's
always necessary for them to charge to
change feet I mean obviously I have to
do it as part of their revenue but they
don't always have to date because I've
had whoa no no change we will just do it
it just depends on the person so I the
$200 change feet that wasn't an answer I
wanted so I hung up the phone and call
right back got a different person and
they said that to get on that flight it
would be six hundred ninety one dollars
this is less than two minutes later they
said six hundred ninety one dollars
which was I was I had my phone pulled up
on kayak at the moment and and it the
flight was only four hundred ninety
dollars anyways that was two hundred
more so I guess they were seeing what
the fare cost plus two hundred dollars
so they said six hundred ninety dollars
to get on that flight and I said that's
not the answer I want at all and then I
call I hang up and I call two minutes
later and then a different person says
that flight is sold out he said sold out
but I'm looking at the seat map on the
American Airlines I it's five seats on
the flight you think they were clocking
your number every time you called I
don't know what the [ __ ] was going I
wouldn't put it past them I don't know
what was going on but they went from 200
change for you to six hundred ninety
dollars to sold out and then it was just
it was four hundred ninety bucks on on
the app and I just booked it right there
on my phone cuz I didn't have time to
keep [ __ ] around with them yeah so
American Airlines I don't know what type
of [ __ ] rodeo bull [ __ ] you got going
on there but I talked to three people in
six minutes and got three different
answers and just booked it myself
because I didn't have time so uh yeah
man dude Airlines what is that I think a
lot of it like on the internet I know
for sure they
like clock in like cookies and stuff
like that like your internet history or
whatever so like though but I think
something about how like there's like an
algorithm of how your behavior is with
checking flights that they mess with the
numbers yeah they were as crooked as
funny will go up on a flight I've had
that hell will go up on a price a few
times yeah man so they might have been
clocking your number every time you
called I don't know but that's a
different change in the flight versus
booking a flight okay guys is it
different that you don't look at the
flight straight up from scratch then
they you know mess with those prices but
if you changing the flight that you
already had then that should be just one
thing so I don't know if these people
these three people are at varying levels
of skill at their jobs
or something and I don't know who the
best at their job was but that was just
thought that was really funny and [ __ ]
up at the same time to me man but that's
that but I flew into New York and New
York City was on on fire this weekend
man this is lives of fun it was a fun it
was an energy field we had Dave
Chappelle hosted SNL and also UFC 205
boycott UFC voted he's the Trump
supporter but man I like white people
get punched in the face
skillfully so I'm just gonna have to you
know just have to watch it I'm just glad
I'm sorry as he says people get punched
it's entertaining I don't know I mean
it's just it's a good product I was
surprised to hear that Dana White is a
trump supporter doesn't come off like a
trump supporter that's you don't that
what does that mean why are the Trump
supporters seem more like you know
they're red it's kind of conservative
types he doesn't have that vibe that's
all I'm saying
and you know I mean there's no -
probably homies
he's known him for like 15 years yeah 16
years but I don't know if there's a sort
I mean what
TV tail is not I don't think there's an
archetype I mean it's probably some of
my friends that are trunk voters and
what was you is it it struck the first
person where you say people I feel like
he's the first when people say Trump
supporters versus Trump voters voters
you serious supporters more you need
Barack Obama supporters as much I don't
know I might be overthinking but I feel
like I hear Trump supporters more than
I've heard about Bush supporters or it
was just more buzz voters on whatever
anyways man so I was trying to figure
out how to maximize this night in New
York with Chappelle being at SNL and UFC
205 happening but SNL is from 11:30 to 1
o'clock and UFC the main card started at
10 o'clock meaning if I went to the main
card I would not be able to catch a
snail if I went to SNL I'll be missing
McGregor against Alvarez and so and I
remembered that SNL as a dress rehearsal
you have a dress rehearsal at 8 p.m. and
sauce I was on the list for the 11:00
thing but I set up and I just like
almost show up and just try to go to the
dress rehearsal and we get there and it
was fun it was kind of gave me anxiety
being in the building it caused so much
going on they didn't have a place for so
I was kind of in the hallway and I was
in the hallway and it's just movement
all the right like you got these like
get to this side at Holiday they coming
through with The Weekend Update desk and
it's just people running around at all
times and it kind of just have my heart
beating fast but it was cool to you know
see my some of my old co-workers and and
see the show and you get the you know
being in the hallway you see people in
their costume right before they they go
out there and it was uh was a fun time
A Tribe Called Quest was there it
performed Busta Rhymes was there I saw
most of the show
Chappell was great and he I see in the
dress rehearsal monologue versus the the
the the real show one he changed it up a
lot man he tightened it up he threw in
some jokes that he definitely didn't do
in the fair it was it was cool to see
the changes and energy and he and how he
brought it together and it was also just
cool to see him on television just doing
sketch comedy yeah just doing sketch
comedy you were meant because I've seen
him you know do stand-up dozens of times
over the past couple years but you know
just seeing him now I thought it would
have been so appropriate for him to do
just like a full on Clayton Bigsby skit
a full one yeah it's like a full-on one
just to kind of address what's been
going on yeah I honestly thought he was
gonna do that yeah what I did a quick
yeah but that sketch was really cool
with the hat he brought all the
characters that was a that was you know
that was great nostalgia um but he's
really good man Kate McKinnon is so good
on Kate McKinnon is always just so
locked in that makeout scene I make it
yes she's really good and I she's I've
met her a handful of times but I'm such
a fan of hers when she walked through
the hallway
I said hey Kate McKinnon I said our food
that's when you know someone's a fan cuz
people do that with you all the time
oh [ __ ] Hannibal Buress you know what's
up you know what people do sometimes as
we were people decided guy at TSA was uh
he I go through that guy grabbed my bag
and he's just kind of like he's snapping
like a madman yeah
is an assay it's okay man I'm not that
famous it's fine he's like a man I'd
like just but uh Netflix and he's Canada
but also you know I won't get mad at but
I also don't I don't give it to them
yeah yeah I know I thought having New
Orleans would you left that guy hanging
but he was like creepily smiling at you
and pointing what did he was like
looking at you is just kind of pointing
going like yeah yeah yeah like he was
waiting for you to say I don't know I
have too much yeah social anxiety
already so you know if I don't have to
have interaction I will try to avoid
like if somebody's like uh-uh
is it you but this is what this dude did
he didn't he you know like it's fine I
don't care
I'm that uses like I don't you know I'm
not that I don't you know I'm not
offended that you don't know my name and
then this was and this is what people do
sometimes he said but he said I bet I'm
the only person here that recognized you
all right well and any person that so
that puts me in a spot where I could say
yeah man cool or I could tell the truth
with it no the other guy did like
somebody it was that he was like the
third person that had spoken to me in
the past couple minutes be like I bet
you I'm the only one here oh this is
what people do sometimes is be chilling
at a bar or something and then I'm just
casually having a good time and then
somebody walk up what's up man hey how's
it going and then nails a dude why is
nobody else why is nobody here freaking
out man why is nobody everything why
does nobody freak at this place to be
going crazy right now
anyway that's this this is ideal that is
very chill I don't know I don't know if
you know what I want
from
I don't know if you know it I will work
from life but it's nice sometimes though
you want it to work out in your favor
like the other day when we're leaving
the hotel
you saw that beautiful beautiful woman
you know it actually made it more fun
that she doesn't know that she did she
did yeah it was his oh man that was so
funny that was this girl was that leave
in Kansas City
yeah we were leaving the hotel oh yeah
it was like some kind of it was a
conference conference yeah and there was
a bunch of beautiful professional women
there but yeah this one she was
beautiful she was tall she might have
been I know so she was ethnic like black
ethnic like maybe she might have been
after yeah
and I just she was talking with her
coworkers it was like 10:00 in the
morning and I was just I knew I had to
say I felt like I had to say something
Express I wanted to engage in
conversation with her but we were
getting in the car and they were about
to get in the car
and so I just said I want to start a
life together the best hail-mary holler
I've ever seen you want to start a life
together but as you can't go that hard
like you kids boy it was funny cuz you
were you were just in a daze by her
beauty you're like ah like in time is
tickin and you're like I gotta do this
and just you went for it man I gave you
props for it cuz that was that was very
very ballsy that might have been one of
the ballsiest things I've ever seen you
do I just went for it said you want to
start a life together I didn't hide it
but I didn't really want to start a life
with her but it is just a very ballsy
opener yeah
just wanna lend them here but I got all
my seats
see a rapper to the beat and I don't get
a seat in a stinky by my feet CD a ride
no to beat seat geek not living in the
street [ __ ] geek in a cool seat geek
what get my seats of seat geek look at
that's not our man Jesus $20 rebate I'll
check his download the free CD yet go to
Settings tab and click Add phone call
it's a bubble called rambling I spy a
mble see you see you twenty dollars
after you made your first $10 for me a
blue apron delivery seasonal recipes
along with free portion ingredients -
like delicious home-cooked meal so if
you single but want to eat great if you
runaway child or a football player
anybody eat food it's for anybody that's
- $10 a meal that's a great deal
accident my life is so dope listen blue
a free legs they get great ingredients
uh sighs the highest quality of the
farmers is no crazy wily coyote don't
even use good farmers let no no before
tight farmers anyone's some nice food
well this Japanese ramen noodles wild
Karl Alaska salmon or heirloom tomatoes
blue apron is bringing you the best some
of the meals available in November
include pan-seared chicken with roasted
fall vegetables and butter caper sauce
spiced mostly
[Music]
yeah S&L is fun it's a good time I had
it over to UFC you f see had some good
seats thanks to everybody over at w and
me I am G for the for the nice seats we
were sitting next to Gordon Ramsay me
and my friend Kay let me just be you
know we had a good time Gordon Ramsay
there ran into Zac Efron they would they
got took a picture of us through there's
me Zac Efron and Gordon Ramsay and then
when he posted it online is that huge
names at UFC 205 exact ever on a gourd
revs and I'm just individual indeed and
they didn't mention it as opposed to
deny that no respect but else I actually
have made it more it was funny because
he caught all that flak for it because
people just took it all so I probably
wouldn't even that if he admitted me I
probably wouldn't have posted the
picture cuz did it but is this funny to
play you know I'm the dog [ __ ] without
Dallas P but it was a first UFC at
Madison Square Garden and it was crazy
man it was crazy must've been insane
it was great we were front row dog like
front row right where they you know the
fighters you know get cleaned up and
[ __ ] and right before they go was enough
to get blood splattered on you know I
don't get any blood it's not that is a
bit of a distance okay got you but yeah
you know what's so crazy about UFC
fighters well just MMA boxing whoever
didn't get kicked in the face you never
hit him just say Wow ouch goddamn like
don't that hurt son damn it man like
you've never mean occasionally if they
break this [ __ ] they might but is it
like a heart how professional punch a
punch for somebody with years and years
of training and they punched you
cleaning your [ __ ] and they you just
take it without even going on oh man but
you hear like grunts right like oh I I
guess so I'm that right there in the
ring but it was uh a fun event man it
was a fun event but Donna was there what
yeah Hugh Jackman was in the building
Swizz Beatz was there Swizz Beatz with
Swizz Beatz Swizz Beatz Swizz Beatz son
is a good producer yeah he made a beat
on that ate the kendrick untitled
unmastered anyways the McGregor fight
was crazy cuz he beat the [ __ ] out of
dude McGregor the way he masterminded
that that guy he's beat him up he will
not even let he be he just the way he
picked him apart like he he fought that
guy like he took a time machine and he's
fought him before and fought him a bunch
of times and then came back and just
fixed all his mistakes like he was
flawless
it was perfect he put on a beautiful
performance
he beat the [ __ ] out of dude it was
amazing it was crazy dude even get any
shots off no it was I was like is this
dead dude didn't even look like a
professional fighter he was just dancing
around him like isn't
even I don't even look at it as like he
beat his ass I look at more as like he
was just toying with him like he's like
you can't touch me I'm gonna just plug
you left and right
do my thing dance around it's a done
deal like it was I'm trying to figure
out why I flawless the guy look so bad
my theory is that it was pretty late it
was about 1:15 1:30 in the morning yeah
he was sleeping man I don't think so I
just think he sleeps he think he was
sleepy and you know McGregor he's Irish
so he was he was on he was on like it
was like 6:30 in the morning where his
probably get up early to Train so it's
1:30 so he five hours ahead and so he's
like on his morning mode that's probably
when he works out and so he's fresh as
hell and his Eddie do is usually sleep
around 1:30 and so he's sleepy kind of
fresh kind of look that sleepy
[ __ ] ass man that's my theory
I know I'm no Joe Rogan it's a very
flawed thing I'm no Jim Norton um no you
know I'm no MMA expert I know you know
but that's what I saw
so your theory is that they both flew in
the day before the fight what they
didn't get time to adjust to the time no
Eddie Alvarez is from Philly
okay think yeah I think he's from Philly
so he is 1:30 for him he was sleepy man
I think he was sleepy I think Connor
probably so you think Connor has like a
permanent Irish clock inside of him
yeah Irish time clock either that or
Connor I think kind of trained
I think Connor had a bunch of sparring
and training fights at 1:30 at night so
he can feel comfortable at that time
fine well that's just good strategy
that's great strategy it's out so Connor
and his team for making those great with
time management great time management
because if you go fight that's late to
be fighting man yeah man that's an
unnatural situation that's the time
usually most fights break out is about
that time but to professionally fight
yeah it was weird leaving the building
leaving Madison Square Garden at 2:00 in
the morning it felt very forward and
weird it was funny we were a couple
seats away from Eddie Alvarez his wife
mm-hmm and she was just screaming like
she right before the fight started
because she was a you know on the in at
the end of the row so right before the
fight started we were sort of in the
middle and so she went past us to the
left yeah Jim Norton was sitting a
couple seats away and she went by dad's
and when Eddie got it now she just
really just screaming and then during
the fight she's just yelling just
screaming his name and this is does this
motivate him or help him cuz I mean why
you screamin is it was it was fascinated
just to be next to a a fighter's wife
while he getting a ass whooped
it was interesting man it was she just
kept on screaming I mean you would you a
fighter's wife you ain't got no strategy
you know [ __ ] maybe that's the real
reason he lost because she was screaming
yeah
and who distracted and so as soon as he
got knocked out she hops over the [ __ ]
to try to run into the ring and then
security comes back Security's tight as
[ __ ] the security it's right on it but
it's one bigger dude that knows that uh
he she's his wife and so he's this is
what other security do to try to get her
out of there and then so I guess they
let either letter it and then you know I
got distracted cuz then they were doing
it you know the post-fight analysis and
Connor was doing his interview and all
that and asking for a second service all
areas here
where's my belt Lucas my second belt no
my second better
where's myself Oh thoroughly enjoyed
that uh and then and so yes so that was
all happening and I don't know what was
happening with her but then the police
walked her out of there
at some point yeah so she got she got
escorted out static he watched your
lover yeah
fighting is tough that family took two
L's also Eddie Alvarez I don't I don't
want any problems I know that you he was
the champ I know and he made the way he
took his ass apart and and on top of
that the guy was the champ
that was a chip like there is no like he
kind of McGregor is he was sleeping man
that's how he's gay what other reason
does a champion what about the ring like
that he was sleeping what about the
theory that Conor McGregor is just
[ __ ] awesome and well rested no I'm
not gonna give you this one Hannibal I'm
not gonna give you this I will not let
this one go prepared and and and rested
man that was B at them hands his hands
no Eddie Eddie man next time you gotta
give him more sleep dog you gotta give
him one sleep and that's my advice to
you Eddie also you don't listen to this
anyways yeah man so fights was fun it
was it was uh I bet on Conor also yeah
yeah it was nice Conor a surprisingly
low odds for how he whooped his ass yeah
it was it was only minus 170 for Conor I
always bet on Conor it was there
thank you yeah Thank You Connor for
helping my finances for the week was
great so then we had it set a S&L
afterparty from there when it's an
after-party
it was at the cutting room in New York
and it was great man
Chappelle's you know it was all Lenny
Kravitz came through played the drums
was a bet it was a crazy event man it
what's like 5:30 in the morning I just
want to thank you for inviting me to all
this Hannibal this man I was on I was on
a date do you think I didn't invite you
because it would make for a better
dynamic for the podcast do you talk
about the Oscar unites like mmhmm yeah
it's dope yeah this makes it know it
makes for a better podcast right can't
you know is for balance he's like oh you
know I can't add those those needed
subtle details don't like what about
yeah and he had a glass of lemonade in
his hand
killing it yeah uh-huh what about that
one part when this is me this isn't that
either energy the energy that you
passing along right now isn't that his
neck good energy man isn't that isn't it
snag good energy anyways man yeah the
party was crazy Chappelle
song karaoke song creep covers this is a
way to go man covers is the way to go
next time I'm excited to do the next
Styx jam I want to do another one just
so I could do a cover which cover would
you do I would do maybe been in the Jets
okay I would do I would do stronger by
Calle I would do what I would do
oh man I would do what more can I say by
jay-z
okay that's a good with the live band
though that's so that's a live band song
right there what's your what's your
go-to karaoke song is Benny an attention
yeah oh man
I'm like I wanna that was maybe I just
put together maybe I just do a jam
session to a half and I don't want to
just put on an event just so I could do
karaoke once let's just go do some
karaoke Brian oh no it's not no no I
want to do cuz we do karaoke at this
places especially if you do a rap song
if you do karaoke at a karaoke night the
beats are weird is something with the
beats where they sound down but they
sound all yeah just you know like that
does this sound like the Kidz Bop
version of the beats well I'm not really
in the rap Carrie okay I feel like
karaoke is more for like singing your
ass off like this is song you really
feeling just like you don't like just go
in yeah sorry my voice sucks right have
you get if you done hip-hop karaoke
before yeah I don't like it this just
feels like with the crap but hip-hop
Carrie I've done it what if the crowd is
it is when the crowd is into it
I've seen this trap karaoke they have
and it's just a crazy energy man it's
wrapped cario trap karaoke what he just
yeah it's trapped oh okay I could see
that I could see like with but like I
will do something like Travis Scott is
it his [ __ ] is like singsong a mmm like
oh no I can't [ __ ] with two lives I love
you have live live auto-tune that Travis
Scott album I got it I gotta tell you
cuz usually when a rapper is like trappy
like he is there'd be like a couple of
cuts and I'm like okay this that's those
are the head so I'm gonna [ __ ] with
those and whatever but that album hasn't
I got I've been listening out in front
to back and I like it it's art it's
artfully done to those good transitions
yeah yes good transitions like right
before is that is that one song and it's
like I want you to pick up the phone
pick up the phone for me yeah and then
it goes oh yeah
pick up the phone baby yeah yeah that's
a great dress it's amazing album it's my
my favorite album so far as 2016 hand
really owns yeah
hands-down my favorite album I think is
the no worries the innocent pack album
yes lawd let's get it that's your
favorite out like front to back elbow oh
I'm winning oh yes Lord I was the first
one to tell you about Anderson Park
I'm with we were on our way to go see
crucial conflict in a ball MJ Jean I
threw it on your like yeah smooth yeah
good yeah I haven't seen him live yet
but I heard yeah a prominence not even
[ __ ] drama yeah real yeah actual
these are talented right killing it he's
a talented musician percentages yeah hey
man I think that's it man
yeah yes love whoo yeah man
thanks a lot for listening you guys
Hannibal Burres it's Tony trip I find
dates come see if you have Phoenix I'll
be at stand-up live November 23rd then
after that [ __ ] out of the game for a
little bit psych I go to Australia the
next week I'll be a psych psych I go to
Australia I'll be in Brisbane Sydney
Melbourne Wales Perth I think Hertz is
yeah I heard this one of them hurt
Sydney Melbourne Brisbane and just
checking out Middleburg Duncan obsessed
or yeah I did an episode of Chris got
this podcast beautiful anonymous check
that out
I'm way quieter on there I was trying to
match Chris's Jill and empathetic at
home you know well I saw something also
I saw something that uh
something announced on Twitter today
about some FlyLo projects yeah I don't
know when that comes out yeah I did
voiceover but Flying Lotus is no movie
cool so who so it was weird man it's
some weird visuals I don't know how you
did that or what it was uh it's pretty
disturbing but uh it was kind of
disturbing but it's some funny stuff and
it was you know always good again yeah
yeah thanks for listening
subscribe review and all that share
peace out
good night alright thanks a lot thanks a
lot for you body skin Kannada thank you
for making a comfortable sward problem
for people to feel like they have the
skin-on-skin contact skin condoms made
from some smooth stuff if you wanna gets
moved up grab the skin condoms and Peter
doll you know what you did not fall in
love get that spinach skin condoms you
know about get all better and I'm that
that that weapon get three skin condoms
yeah I don't want no polyps and use cold
Rambla from today's show to see free
shipping on all skin products and buy
condoms done online that's cold
rambling and buy condoms dot online in
1962 a mysterious strangler committed
the first of 13 random murders shocking
Boston and the world who were these
women and why would anyone want to kill
them it was the largest manhunt in the
city's history what is Mary Sullivan's
picture doing on the front page of the
paper with the Boston Strangler fifty
years later the cases remain open
Stranglers the new crime series from
Earwolf subscribe now in itunes stitcher
or google play
this has been an ear wolf production
executive produced by Scott Aukerman and
Chris Bannon for more information and
content visit Earwolf dot-com
you